and you where you from originally
where'd you grow up
Lucy Alma what part of Louisiana sweet
part Shreveport and you tell me about
your family you grew up with both your
parents huh tell me about your family
you grew up with both of your parents uh
I grew up with my grandparents because
my mother and father passed away when I
was young I lost my dad when I was nine
I lost my mom I'm 13
so my father's mom my grandmother raised
us and how was your childhood huh how
was your childhood my father how was he
how was your childhood hi how was your
childhood how old how was your child my
father was okay but he was like up he
was never home he was always you know
out there with the others you know um
selling here or stuff like that
my grandmother didn't like it because my
mother was on it and he always had the
supplies for her you know she didn't
have to worry about going to get it
right was this I guess by him giving it
to her he got hooked off so you know she
hated her ever since then so your answer
is yeah because my father she said she
turned him into one yeah and then you
you left home at what age uh 16 where'd
you go I was living in I was in the
valley that Fernando Valley with my
grandparents and I just got tired of
getting yelled and beaten you know for
any little dump stuff [ __ ] you know
anything was stupider crap I don't know
my grandma was a mean person okay she
was very wicked I just got tired I
called the police I ran away oh the
police I don't know
Vinson either put me in a foster home
because it got tired of the [ __ ] my
auntie she said reading one of them just
take her away so they put me in a foster
home you know and I stayed you cha was
about six days seventeen days I got you
know I got out there mom you're on your
own how was I guess all Cravens I'm
still here you are you know saying I've
been after on on the streets on my own
just survived is called surviving yeah
doing what I got to do too soon to live
do you get married and I'm 58 years old
I made it this far so good you're
getting married a kiss
no no it's like I had an old man but it
was like it wasn't a good relationship
you know when it didn't have his where
didn't like I didn't like getting hit
because I got tired when I getting hit
you know I saw no I've got this going
right back at me I'm leaving it from I'm
trying to get away from my grandparents
doing it now he'd oh you know I just got
like got me all confused in the brain
yeah that's why they put me under a
doctor of like a psych because I was
shaking I I have mental problems I used
to have night wake up crying out of my
sleep because things I have flashbacks
what my grandparents did or something
happened to me with my old man did I
have bad I just had bad dreams yeah you
know it's just like I don't know I just
had me like out of it so they gave me
some um some nert some some pills to
calm my nerves and it helped me sleep
and relax because I just I'm a lot
better now but before if you see me
before then now you wouldn't believe it
I was like a nervous wreck everything
anybody you know just calm down we're
not gonna do nothing to come I couldn't
always just they had me like that
it took me a long time to come up
the doctor saying that was because of
the things that have happened to me in
the past yeah being yelled up being hit
because every time you raise your hammer
I don't know what won't get hit again or
what you don't say it's just it's just
having me all shook up the doctor says
that's that's a natural cause that's
from that that could happen to anyone
stress you from a chap I was a child
basically from a child up to adults
because my old man used to do not just
mother my first one used to do it you
don't say oh no a normal is getting
popped around pop crap you know for no
reason and a person get well I know I do
I get tired of it why should I get hit
for something I don't do if anything I'm
after surviving China has helped both of
us you know this is when I was living in
Hollywood before I came here you know
everything I did was some both of us you
know I never cheated on him
I never went behind his back I don't
know I think he likes the icky ones okay
he likes the ones that he could just
slap around back you know but I'm not
going I wasn't going for that because I
didn't do it to get that but he was
doing it every time somebody look he
sound eyeball name when they look you to
have somebody just walk by and look at
you oh now y'all I contacted I mean I
already know what you talking about I
see him looking at you I see I said naw
you're wrong this man looking I mean
he's looking at me that don't mean I'm
looking at him you know you don't want
to see now all that I'm not you know is
I don't know what I just used to get so
sick I didn't know what to do sometime I
just run from him can I be so scared how
long a road baby huh how long have you
been here on Skid Row down here yes I've
been there five years now in my place
yeah so that's how long five years
excuse me no no hotels apartment it's a
single back to learn apartment good
before that it was like motel to motel
that cost a lot of money
yeah I've been here five years and if
you use any of the drug center on the
street I did in Hollywood years ago and
stuff you know but now no you're
cleaning though I just get nervous not I
just have a nervous condition everything
scares me you know
I'm just hot I don't know I get tired
I'm getting old I'm 58 years old I guess
everything is getting I'm just getting
tired of everything seem like my body
just wants to shut down but I don't want
myself to shut down you know I'm trying
to keep myself motivated keep going keep
going keep going so I have to do what I
got to do to keep going you know oh yeah
people offered me a joint people offer
me a drink I don't do none of that
people I'll be here whatever else you
know I just tailed enough I done I did
that and done that I don't want it no
more because if I might get the wrong
car you might give me something wrong
and then they might kill me I don't know
what I'm messing with and this is like
58 years ago cuz I'm 58 you know say
that's been a long time for me yeah I'm
still out here doing what I'm doing on
the street but I'm doing that for me to
survive what do you do for money
I'm what I did okay I get like a hundred
something every month but that food goes
so fast you know basically it's for my
food by singer because I smoke cigarette
you don't stuff like that and got
nothing the money I make has nothing to
do with drugs
everything is this something for me if I
need you lot money to wash clothes or
whatever do my laundry you don't say
or if I need a new pair of under or
whatever you know but then I don't get
all that money that I should get maybe
20 here 40 now they gonna get all what I
want just follow me we follow I'm saying
so I have to go out every day to get
what I need
till I get it all where I want till I
get all what I want you know it might
take a while but I'll get it eventually
what do you do to make extra money do
you huh what do you do to make extra
money extra money of whatever they're
like golden showers or just a straight
day or find him another girl you know
oh excuse me your date guy sometimes huh
you will date guys sometimes you'll go
out with guys sometimes that's what we
do or not I take guys yeah
that's how I make money that's what I'd
be doing now now yeah did I have some
regulars you know some of them who
really liked me they come back and we
just hang out or whatever they take me
out to you you know it's just now how
about having sex it's about them not
it's all about no to know a person get
to know first because you never know
when you might need a help we all need
somebody in our corner you know we all
do and that's what that's how I look at
it you know hey if I got the rubber or
if they got the rubber hey we'll date
but if you ain't got no rubber sorry
Charlie ain't no dating happening
because you're not gonna catch me you
ain't gonna give me no aids or honor or
whatever that is you know what's that
because I don't know who that
president's been with before that person
got with me you follow me and if he when
he ever comes home I don't want to give
it to him cuz he ain't doing nothing in
jail unless he bustin back the back over
let me hush that's enough I don't wanna
talk about more about that stuff okay no
problem
can I go now I have to keep wasting my
brother all brother
okay baby thank you I appreciate it oh
you haven't no covers up I guess of
water yeah cuz I'm talking my mouth